president Trump declares his trade war
on hold the White House cracks down on
CNN and Republicans go after Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein will
talk about it I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
many a new piece of news will meet my
eye many a new day shall find me well
we'll talk about all of the things that
are breaking in the news first I need to
let you know that if you have not
actually bought a ticket yet for our
live events in Dallas and Phoenix what
are you doing what are you doing okay we
have a Ben Shapiro show live this August
Dallas and Phoenix but you should know
that we are now 80% sold out of both
events and we still have a month to go
which means it's going to sell out if
you haven't gotten your tickets yet you
should get them now or else you could
miss out on this event entirely Plus
right now we are also selling you should
know Ben Shapiro Live Tour shirts over
at amazon.com so go check that out as
well because we announced yesterday that
they're a bunch of colleges we'll be
visiting
so go check that out too also I should
remind you that our national debt is 21
trillion dollars in Counting right and I
remember when we used to care about that
sort of stuff that is a bunch of money
that we owe the social security fund and
money that we have borrowed from other
countries via bonds well that debt is
greater than the entire economic output
of the United States if your entire life
savings is tied to the US dollar you
should ask yourself what your plan is
for inflation or if the stilts fall out
from under the economy a hedge against
inflation and a hedge against
uncertainty and stability it is precious
metals gold is a safe haven against
uncertainty which is why my savings plan
is diversified and yours should be - the
company I trust with precious metals
purchases is you know it Birch gold
group and right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
which is perfect for people who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from any future geopolitical
uncertainty when you look back
historically what you see is that when
the bottom falls out of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau you all know about Birch Gold's
free information kit but for a limited
time qualified purchases can earn up to
an additional 10 grand in precious
metals for free through July 31st to
find out if your purchase qualifies go
to birchgold.com slash men talk to a rep
birchgold.com slash men let them know
that we sent you again the offer only
runs until July 31st terms and
limitations apply ask your sales
representative for details
ok so yesterday was an epic day of good
Trump bad Trump which is a great excuse
for us to bring back our good Trump bad
Trump jingle lets women done this in a
long time guys I'm excited let's bring
it back good Trump bad Trump guys go
[Music]
every day is a mystery I'm good Trump
bad Trump you never know what you're
going to find behind door number one or
door number two well I've been talking
for several weeks about the silliness of
trade wars about why you don't rally
terrifying you don't increase tariffs in
order to increase prices on your own
citizens and increase prices on inputs
and sync your own economy simply to
punish other countries the president
however likes tariffs a lot but
yesterday he went weapons down with the
EU so he tweeted out yesterday that he
had made a deal with the EU he said
great meeting on trade today with yoga
EU Jonker of course is the is the head
of the EU since we have come to a very
strong understanding and all believers
and are all believers in no tariffs no
barriers and no subsidies that would be
John Claude Younker by the way he says
work on documents has already started
and the process is moving along quickly
European Union nations will be open to
the United States and at the same time
benefitting by everything we are doing
for them there was great warmth and
feeling in the room a breakthrough has
been quickly made that nobody thought
possible actually I mean to be a little
affair pretty much everybody thought
that was possible so long as we just
said we're not gonna raise our tariffs
and you're not gonna raise your tariffs
in then we get to be friends again this
is great to be back on track with the
European Union this was a big day for
free and fair trade now it was a good
day for free and fair trade one of the
big questions here is whether it was
Trump's tough talk with the EU that
caused them to lower some of their
tariffs on American products that is I
would say unclear at best just to be
completely honest now I'm fine with the
president leveraging and threatening if
he gets them to lower their tariffs that
is fine with me and then we lower our
tariffs and everything is all better so
I don't care that's fine I'm very
pleased that the president has moved in
this direction it was unclear this is
the direction the president was going to
move because on the one hand he likes
tariffs a lot he thinks tariffs are
inherently good and on the other hand he
was saying well what we should all aim
for is no tariffs so which was it was
this just a negotiating ploy or was this
the president speaking his true feelings
on tariffs and then his administration
sort of fixing it in the back room
either way the outcome isn't the same
and the outcome is good The Wall Street
Journal editorial board was very excited
about this this morning they say the
meeting on Trade Wednesday between
President Trump and European Commission
President jean-claude Juncker had all
the makings of a potential crack-up but
in the event it provided the best
economic news in weeks financial markets
were clearly pleased as stocks rose
across the board before the closing bell
on the statements by the two presidents
after their White
session call it a relief rally the two
sides essentially declared a tariff
truce pending negotiations on a larger
trade deal between the 28-nation
European Union and the u.s. mr. Trump
agreed to step back from his threat of
25% tariffs on European car imports
while the two sides pledged to resolve
the current u.s. steel and aluminum
tariffs and Europe's retaliatory levies
on u.s. goods
Europe Europe also agreed to buy more
soybeans immediately and much more
liquefied natural gas from the United
States in the future as its import
capacity expands that particularly is a
good thing that the EU is now going to
import a bunch of American liquefied
natural gas it cuts off the market for
the Russians who are increasing their
power and their influence in the
European Union by shipping all sorts of
natural gas to that area LNG export
capacity is expected to nearly triple by
2022 nine point six billion cubic feet a
day as more export terminals come online
and the fracking boom continues and more
importantly the two sides agreed to
negotiate a larger trade deal that mr.
Trump said would have as a goal zero
tariffs zero non-tariff barriers and
zero subsidies on non auto industrial
goods well I wish that he would extend
it to auto industrial goods I don't
think that we should maintain all of
these trade barriers with regard to
autos and motorcycles but it is good
that everybody is back at the table The
Wall Street Journal points out that
Europe has a ten percent tariff on u.s.
made cars the u.s. charges only 2.5
percent on cars made in Europe but we
charge with 25 percent tariffs on
imported trucks and Europe will want the
United States to take that to zero which
won't please forward and US companies
let's all hope that this is all honest
and everybody wants to get to zero
tariffs and zero subsidies and that we
all want to get to a perfectly free
trade scenario now was it President
Trump that caused all this a lot of his
champions today are saying that this was
Trump at his very best this is Trump
making a deal by raising tariffs
threatening the EU and then the EU
backing down Trump seems to believe the
same thing here's what he had to say
yesterday from in a hastily called press
conference at the Rose Garden we've
never done like we're doing I can say
from the standpoint of the United States
we've never done this well but we're
going to do a lot better after we do
this deal and other deals that we're
currently working on I had the intention
to make a deal today and we made a deal
today
so Trump is very very happy of course
because anytime somebody says that a
deal was made he's a happy camper
president Trump of course is a deal make
this is how he pictures himself and if a
deal got made the president gets credit
for it no matter what tactics he used in
order to in order to engage in it now
did we actually have to threaten the EU
with all these really high tariffs in
order to get them to lower some of their
barriers on soybeans probably not the
reality is that the EU just signs a
massive trade deal with Japan the United
States could have been a part of there's
a piece over at national review by
Matthew Rooney from just a couple of
days ago talking about the deal between
the EU and Japan says this the EU and
Japan just signed a trade agreement
while the u.s. sat on the sidelines this
is a bad move on America's part because
late comers will ultimately find
themselves with no option but to accept
the terms of the deal how do we know
that it was America's own strategy with
the general post-war agreement on
tariffs and trade that's GATT NAFTA and
the central american free trade
agreement known as CAFTA as well as the
World Trade Organization itself the
European Union with an economy similar
in size to Americas at 25 percent of
global GDP has teamed up with Japan
which produces another five percent of
global GDP to take the lead so why was
the u.s. missing from the table first
because we abandon the trans-pacific
partnership that would be TPP there are
problems with TPP as negotiated by
Barack Obama but I think it was a
mistake I said so at the time to scrap
TPP and I think that instead President
Trump should have gone in and opened up
some of those provisions to
congressional approval obviously also
President Trump continues to muck about
with NAFTA and he's unclear on whether
we are going to allow NAFTA to move
forward or not everybody else is
creating these great trade bloc's in the
United States is sort of picking and
choosing trade deals some of which are
beneficial and some of which seem
relatively minimal nonetheless this is
good Trump okay bottom line is tariffs
come down trade barriers go away that is
good Trump and President Trump gets
credit for the e lowering its trade
barriers even if I think that this sort
of threatening language with regards to
tariffs is unnecessary we'll also have
to see the final product we will have to
see the final product of the agreement
will have to see the text of the
agreement we'll have to see whether the
tariffs actually do come down so that
indeed is good Trump more good Trump was
the Trump administration officials from
the Trump administration coming forward
and and making clear that American
policy on Russia is not going to weaken
anytime soon so we've been hearing ever
since the Helsinki conference last week
between President Trump and Vladimir
Putin we've been hearing that the
president of the United States is weak
on Russia he's in the pay of the
Russians we hear this from Adam Schiff
we hear this from various members of the
Democrat
caucus that Trump is a secret agent on
the roof keys well that actually is not
true as evidenced by the policy of the
administration now I suggested in the
last couple of weeks that there is this
massive gap between President Trump's
rhetoric and the actions of his
administration and it's one of the
reasons I think that the left can't
understand why so many conservatives
support President Trump they say well
President Trump says crazy things you
never accept from Barack Obama and the
answer is right but then none of that
stuff happens so in president Trump's
has a lot of nice things to Vladimir
Putin none of it actually materializes
also I do have to acknowledge that this
is hilarious you know when when when
Vladimir Putin the dictator of Russia
actually remembered he handed Donald
Trump a soccer ball remember this hand
I'm a soccer ball as a sort of memento
that he was going to keep from this
conference it turns out the soccer ball
did indeed have embedded inside it a
chip that allowed it to broadcast to
cell phones in the area so it actually
was a spy device apparently there's a
report that it was actually a spy device
that was handed to Donald Trump but
Donald Trump did not fall for it because
Donald Trump knows soccer that's a man
who knows his football right there so
does any of this does any of Trump's
rhetoric actually make a difference it's
a serious question that we have to that
we have to answer with regard to all of
these policies you talk stuff on the ear
but then he sides a trade deal with them
which is good he talks week on Russia
but then his administration is pretty
harsh on Russia Mike Pompeo who's the
new Secretary of State the Newton in the
news and improved Secretary of State he
is testifying before Congress he says
listen we haven't changed our policy on
the Russians invading Crimea and the
Ukraine they need to get out well what
about all the talk that this
administration was The Manchurian
Candidate that it was in the pay of
Vladimir Putin not so much it was Mike
Pompeo today the Trump administration is
releasing what we're calling the Crimea
declaration one part reads as false
quote the United States calls on Russia
to respect the principles to which it
has long claimed to it here and to end
its occupation of Crimea okay so all of
that is good and then Pompeo continues
they listen we're not weak on Russia and
they keep saying we're weak on Russia
we're not the Obama administration guys
like the president may say some stuff
but him saying stuff doesn't necessarily
mean that's the stuff that's actually
implemented it's it's important senator
in comparison matters here because
there's a narrative that is developed
that somehow President Trump is weak on
Russia and it when in fact the cone
let me just room okay and then bob
menendez the the terrible senator from
new jersey he starts trying to go after
Pompeo suggesting of course that
President Trump is indeed soft on Russia
and Pompeyo just destroys him senator
I'm telling you what he had a
conversation with Vladimir Putin about
and I'm telling you what US policy is
today I understand senator I understand
the game that you're playing no no you
know mister okay all due respect I don't
appreciate you characterizing my
questions okay but I don't appreciate
the questions characterizing the Trump
administration as some sort of lacking
institution for the Russians it's just a
bunch of nonsense and just a second I'm
gonna explain why trumps slight
disconnect from his administration
actually sometimes is a good thing but
first let's talk about how you eat and I
don't mean that you're not eating
healthy I don't mean that you're not
eating good food I mean you're not
eating home cooking okay you're going
out to restaurants too much let's be
honest about this you're spending all
your money going out to restaurants and
you don't actually get the joy of
cooking with your kids so I have two
kids under five I love cooking with them
every morning I get up with them and we
make eggs together and it's a blast and
they break a couple eggs on the floor
it's a giant mess but it's a lot of fun
well you can cook with your family and
make better food and then just eggs with
our friends at blue apron blue apron is
an awesome meal delivery service okay
they have all sorts of great stuff we're
talking Honey Chipotle glazed chicken
with poblano and lime rice we're talking
about moving these meals right here
we're talking about let's see sweet
chili beef and vegetable stir-fry with
garlic rice barbecue vegetable flatbread
with Swiss cheese I mean all this stuff
is gourmet stuff and you could be making
it in your own kitchen with your kids
tonight
they provide convenience and variety
blue aprons livers fresh pre-portion
ingredients and step-by-step recipes
directly to your door they can be cooked
in under 45 minutes the menu changes
every week based on what's in season
it's designed by blue aprons in-house
culinary team blue apron offers 12 new
recipes every week customers can pick
two three or four recipes it's awesome
stuff people around the office get blue
apron and they really really enjoy it
and right now you can check out this
week's menu get your first three meals
for free at blue aprons comm slash
Shapiro that's blue apron comm slash
Shapiro to get your first three meals
for free blue apron is indeed a better
way to cook go use that promo code
Shapiro it lets them know that we sent
you okay so president Trump's policies
continue to be quite good even if his
rhetoric continues to be not so good now
all we need is for
rhetoric to actually mirror his policies
if President Trump's rhetoric mirrored
his policies he'd be in a lot better
shape right now and I say this as
somebody who wants the President of the
United States to succeed because I like
a lot of the policies his administration
is putting in place one of the one of
the problems however that I'm seeing is
and this is where the bad Trump comes in
the president's rhetoric does matter
when it comes to some of the polling
data there was a poll yesterday shows
Democrats are now plus 12 in the
Congressional generic ballot okay that
is not a good number there were two
separate polls having Democrats up 12
that means the Democrats not only take
the house there's a good shot they take
the Senate as well they're Republicans
who are now running behind in Arizona
which is insane they should not be
running behind in Arizona where there's
a very very good candidate running
martha mcsalley
now they should not be running behind in
in some of these other states they
shouldn't be running behind joe Manchin
in West Virginia the reddest state in
America by Trump vote yeah there's just
no way they should be happening Trump's
approval ratings are still where they
were but when you dig down what you see
is some trouble for president Trump
there's a poll from NBC News today in
the swing states Michigan Minnesota
Wisconsin and the poll is does Trump
deserve reelection in Michigan only 28%
of voters say Donald Trump deserves
reelection
62% of voters say he does not deserve
reelection that someone else deserves a
chance
those numbers are 30% Pro 60% con in
Minnesota
31% Pro 63% con in Wisconsin and all of
that these are dangerous numbers for the
president now the president can still
win the next presidential election
without winning Wisconsin Michigan or
Minnesota
if he wins Pennsylvania and Ohio and
Florida he's okay but suffice it to say
that if the president's policies were
actually mirrored in his rhetoric he'd
be a lot more popular so I know a lot of
his base thinks that his policies can
only happen because of his rhetoric I
hear I hear listen I hear I hear the
argument I just don't think that the
argument happens to be particularly
compelling I think that this president
could get his policies done simply by
saying what his policy is if he went to
the EU and he said listen you guys are
our friends let's lower the tariffs and
then they said no and then he said okay
well then we're going to have to ratchet
up the pressure I think that would be a
lot better instead he sort of
preemptively ratchets up pressure
because he likes tariffs for example and
then when the tariffs comes down it's
unclear whether it was because of
Trump's action or because we could have
gotten this deal in the first place when
it comes to Russia the president could
say listen Russia meddled with the 2016
election it did not have an impact
and the final outcome but we are going
to stop all that because we are tougher
on Russia than the prior administration
was no matter what the media have to say
he could say all of those things the
fact that he doesn't create suspicion in
the mind of voters that is unnecessary
that is unnecessary and
counterproductive and and a waste of
time so the president is doing himself
no service with his rhetoric that's the
bad from the good Trump is good things
are getting done the bad Trump is he
saying bad things I know Trump
supporters say well why do you care what
he says Kennedy does instead if you care
about him being reelected if you care
about Republicans maintain in Congress
what he says matters to okay speaking of
which let's talk about some actual bad
Trump yesterday's there's a big news
story yesterday where a woman named
Caitlin Collins who works for CNN she
formerly worked for the Daily Caller she
was essentially barred from the White
House she was denied access to an open
press event in the Rose Garden why
because she was the pool reporter
earlier in the day and she asked
President Trump some questions that
apparently he didn't like according to
CNN they said we demand better the
network said Collins was told by deputy
chief of staff for communications bill
Shine and press secretary Sarah Sanders
that her questions were inappropriate
now she was representing the White House
press pool at the time the way this
works for folks who don't understand and
that it's not like a bevy of reporters
just gets a follow president Trump
around there's usually one reporter
who's assigned for part of the day to
ask the president questions in sort of
smaller areas and that person's
questions are then distributed with the
answers to the entire press pool so that
that's very very common it happens at
rallies all the time because all the
networks basically agree that they're
going to cooperate in asking these
questions and then distributing the
answers CNN says this decision to Bower
member of the press is retaliatory in
nature and not indicative of an open and
free press press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said that Collins quote
sorted questions and refused to leave
despite being asked for PETA leader to
do so subsequently our staff informed
her she was not welcome to participate
in the next event I made clear that any
other journalist from her network could
attend she said it didn't matter to her
because she hadn't planned to be there
anyway to be clear we support a free
press and asked that everyone be
respectful of the presidency and guests
at the White House here is Caitlin
Collins talking about this yesterday on
CNN this of course turned into a big
blow up so I was blocked from intending
an open press event here at the White
House because the White House did not
like the questions I posed to president
Trump earlier in the day during an event
in
the Oval Office with the President of
the European Commission okay so it's an
open press event and she was calling out
some questions on behalf of the press
pool and then Trump basically booted her
from a future White House press
conference at the Rose Garden and this
became a huge story because the idea was
she asked tough questions Trump didn't
like it and now they're going to prevent
her from entering now Trump says it was
because she was rude well if that were
the case then Jim Acosta should be
barred for life from the White House I
mean the guy's rude every single day but
that's not the way any of this should
work now in the name of consistency I
think the press should be aggressive
with the executive branch I like it when
the press is aggressive with the
executive branch I think that's their
job and I think they should have been
much more aggressive with Obama my
critique is the double standard that
they weren't aggressive with Obama and
they were aggressive with President Bush
and they are aggressive with President
Trump right the press are definitely to
the left and that manifests itself but
the proper response to that is that the
press should actually be aggressive with
President Obama as well Bret Baier I
thought said it correctly Bret Baier
over on Fox News yesterday he said
listen all of us in the press were on
the same side here that means that it's
our job to ask tough questions
you got all sorts of flack for this I
think Brett bearer is basically correct
here as a member of the White House
press pool Fox stands firmly with CNN on
this issue of access so far no response
from the White House okay Bret Baier got
all sorts of crap for this but again you
should want a press asking questions
your real critique of the press should
be they didn't ask questions to
Democrats not the Republicans should be
able to boot people now I'll show you an
example of the double standard here with
regard to the press coverage so this was
an event at the White House and this
person was called a hecklers a
transgender quote-unquote heckler who
was present at some press conference
that Obama was doing with Joe Biden and
this transgender reporter started asking
questions about the deportation of LGBT
immigrants and Obama tossed the person
to the cheers of members of the press
yeah hold on say that okay you know what
that guy no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no hey yeah listen
you're my house okay and they he had the
person tossed now this is characterized
as a heckler the same thing happened to
neil munro you remember neil munro is a
reporter for The Daily Caller and at a
White House press conference in the Rose
Garden neil munro called out a question
to president obama the entire press
sided against neil munro neil munro was
asked to apologize to the President of
the United States my feeling is that the
press should be as abrasive with the
President as they feel like being I like
the back-and-forth of politics I think
that this sort of abrasiveness from the
press is good not bad I held that
standard when when Obama was president I
hold that standard when President Trump
is president this is a bad look for the
White House and it's something that they
probably should not have done so that is
that is some bad Trump right there is it
I think it's easily fixable but it just
/ it creates a perception that Trump is
not Pro Free Press which i think is is
at least somewhat inaccurate okay in
just a second I want to talk about some
bad GOP because I think that some of my
friends in the house people I like
people who I know are making a bad move
in the House of Representatives I'll
explain that in just a second and then I
want to get to the craziest editorial of
the day from the New York Times first
let's talk about your impending doom so
you're gonna die soon okay let's be real
about this in the in the span of
eternity there's before and there's
after there's a little speck in the
middle that is called your life and when
you pass the question is going to be
whether you actually left your family
with any way of paying for your funeral
the way you do that is you have life
insurance or you don't want to leave
your family without any money without
any redress and that's why you need to
go over to policy genius calm it's the
easy way to compare life insurance
online you can compare quotes in just
five minutes when it's that easy putting
it off becomes a lot harder you can
compare quotes while you're sitting on
the couch watching TV you can compare
quotes while listening to this podcast
you just go try it policy genius has
already helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy they
do all insurance they do disability
insurance and renter's insurance and
health insurance you care about it they
cover it so if you need life insurance
but you've been putting it off because
you're a lazy bum don't do it anymore
go check out policy genius com the easy
way to compare top insurers and find the
best
you for you know sales pressure no
hassle it's free policy genius.com you
got nothing to lose except for that
feeling of insecurity upon your
impending doom go check it out policy
genius.com
right now and go get yourself some life
insurance really it's something anything
any serious person should have okay
meanwhile and the GOP has decided to
file articles of impeachment against Rod
Rosenstein so rod Rosenstein who is the
Deputy Attorney General he's in hot
water because a lot of the members of
the House the Republicans are very upset
that the Deputy Attorney General is not
fast enough to turn over records from
the DOJ with regard to for example the
FISA application for Carter page as well
as records of the Trump Russia collusion
investigation and that they're very
unhappy with the DOJ for all of this so
yesterday house freedom caucus leaders
mark meadows and Jim Jordan both of whom
I'm friendly with both of my liked
escalated their fight with the Justice
Department introducing a resolution to
impeach Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein the resolution is not a sign
the house is about to vote to impeach
Rosenstein as House Judiciary Chairman
Bob Goodlatte and House Oversight
Chairman trey Gowdy who have been
pushing for documents from the DOJ did
not sign on the house is leaving for a
month-long recess after Thursday this is
the part where you start to say this
looks like a publicity ploy and I say
that with all due respect to
representatives who I like and I'm
friendly with it looks like a publicity
ploy if you can't get an actual vote on
the impeachment if it just looks like
we're going to file for impeachment and
then we won't hold a vote and they you
know if you're actually going to try and
beat somebody you got to try and impeach
them by the way very few people have
ever been impeached in the United States
like nineteen people in the entire
course of the history of the country
have been actually impeached by the
house and I think only eight have been
convicted by the Senate removed from
office and the resolution is the
strongest step that conservative allies
of President Trump have taken in their
feud with Rosenstein and the Justice
Department in a statement medow said
Rosenstein should be impeached because
of the Justice Department's stonewalling
of congressional subpoenas and hiding
information from Congress and for
signing one of the thighs a-- act
surveillance warrant renewals for trump
campaign for its foreign policy advisor
carter page well that last excuse right
that Rosenstein signed on to the far as
the FISA warrant renewal application
I find that uncompelled given that we
don't actually know what's in that
warrant application right now right
we've only seen the
two pages of redactions we don't
actually know what was in there so
before you impeach a guy over signing a
warrant renewal that may in fact not be
bad you may want to see what's behind
the redactions there's also a bigger
problem for the republicans here and
that bigger problem is pretty simple it
turns out that rod Rosenstein can be
trumped literally trumped president
Trump can simply release all these
documents tomorrow rod Rosenstein is a
member of the executive branch the DOJ
is an apartment of the executive branch
all Mark Meadows and Jim Jordan have to
do is walk across the street to the
White House go into the Oval Office and
say mr. president tell rod Rosenstein
that it's his job to release these
documents or declassify them yourself
just go do that Trump hasn't done that
which suggests to me that there is
something weird going on I've asked
members of the house about this like why
is it the president Trump doesn't just
release this information and then
members of the House people like Devin
Newton's will tell me they'll say well
because President Trump doesn't want to
interfere in the investigation so let me
get this straight Congress is going to
interfere in the investigation by going
after members of the Trump cabinet right
going after members of the Trump team
but Trump can't interfere in the
investigation by releasing documents
into public view that doesn't wash for
me and I think that it's I think it's me
saying even Andrew McCarthy over at
National Review who's been a legal
booster of the president in the Muller
investigation he says basically the same
thing he says you know going after
Rosenstein is obviously of secondary
consideration plus how's this gonna go
you impeach Rosen so let's say you get
what you want not gonna happen let's say
you get what you want Rosenstein goes
away and then President Trump nominate
somebody new to fill that slot and then
the Republicans approve that somebody
new and that person walks through the
front door and fires Bob Muller you
think the blowbacks not going to be on
Trump what do you think's gonna cause
more blowback Republicans impeaching
Rosenstein replacing him and having that
person fire Muller or the President of
the United States just declassified
documents said the entire public can see
them the answer of course is that the
first is going to be significantly more
burdensome to the future of a trump
presidency than the president just
releasing all of these documents himself
also it's worth noting you know many
impeachment articles were filed against
members of the Obama administration when
Republicans were in charge of Congress
giant zero
giant zero Eric Holder was held in
contempt by Congress and theoretically
Congress could hold Brad Rosenstein in
contempt theoretically they could hold
them in jail beneath the house there
actually is a jail beneath the house
we're holding people in contempt
really but if you're only
file for contempt against Eric Holder
who's a lot worse than rod Rosenstein
I'm not sure my Rhodes esteem gets
impeached under a Republican president
you can talk too but Eric Holder who
considered himself Barack Obama's
wingman and on behalf of whom Barack
Obama declared executive privilege does
not get impeached so Eric holes are no
impeachment rod Rosenstein impeachment I
don't buy it I just don't maybe maybe
there's a good excuse I have yet to hear
it I haven't seen enough on this that
makes me feel comfortable with what the
Republicans are doing here now speaking
of stupid moves there's an article in
The New York Times today from the
execrable Jessica Valencia I know it's a
word I use too much ex-girl but so many
people are just full of it okay Jessica
Valenti is the author of six books on
feminism which makes her just a drag at
parties got to tell you but she is the
author most recently of the memoir sex
object which is weird and she has a
piece in The New York Times today called
what feminists can do for boys now this
could actually be a three word editorial
what feminists could do for boys leave
them alone right and then we could
actually just he'll move on with their
lives that's not what Jessica Valenti
wants us to do just have a couple NT
thinks that we should not leave the boys
alone feminist mutts teach boys to be
feminists teach boys not to rape teach
boys to be little girls basically I mean
that's that's really what this editorial
says so she writes this one of the many
political ironies of our time is that
feminism's most powerful cultural moment
has coincided with the rise of extreme
misogyny while women protests run for
office and embrace the movement for
gender equality and record numbers a
generation of young mostly white men are
being radicalized into believing that
the problem stem from women's progress
well no I don't think that men believe
that women in the workplace is a real
problem or women being able to choose
what they want to do with their with
their with their sex lives I don't get a
lot of young men who object to that
frankly I don't think there are a lot of
men who are sitting around thinking man
these women
I wish they'd go back to the kitchen
this is a feminist canard that all of us
are sitting here going yeah you know
what I wish my way for barefoot and
pregnant in the kitchen it turns out
that my wife can be barefoot pregnant in
the kitchen and work a full-time job as
a doctor Wow lots of things happening
right there it turns out just unlike
wearing slippers that's not my fault she
wants her slippers in the kitchen while
cooking and then I'll help her cook and
then she goes in she is a doctor saving
people's life that's fine
that's fine but this there's this age
from the feminists left that young men
who feel emasculated by the feminist
movement they feel emasculated because
they fear women's empowerment I don't
fear women's empowerment
I fear emasculation I'd like a lot of
people fear emasculation
I fear the idea that feminists actually
want men not to protect women they want
men not to be masculine they want men
not to be men and have responsibilities
for taking care of women and children
they want to read masculinity out of the
world and then they are surprised when
men object to this and talk a little bit
more about this in just one second we'll
continue with Jessica Valenti's horrible
op-ed in the New York Times in just
second but first I want to talk about
your health okay the one constant in
life has changed Society changes
technology changes health innovations
change as well to stand the cutting edge
of today's fast-paced business
environment you can't rely on energy
drinks and coffee to get you through the
day first of all a lot of stuff in
particularly healthy to crack the code
on human performance there's a team of
top physicians and they've gathered to
form Brickhouse nutrition they came up
with a great products called
dawn-to-dusk it's the most advanced
formula to stimulate your heart brain
and cells by providing clean energy and
focus for up to 10 hours no Jenner's no
afternoon crash I remember when the ad
agency president who represents brick
house actually came to visit us in the
office last month he'd flown all around
the country and the guy what's up I mean
there's a lot of energy in him and the
reason was that is because he was taking
dawns dusk and then he was just tearing
through his business meetings some of
our producers have been taking it let me
just say their output has increased
dramatically dawn to dusk will make you
the sharpest guy in the conference call
the brightest mind in the meeting the
envy of the entire office end you're not
gonna have to make yourself less healthy
with sugary coffee and and energy drinks
that give you heart palpitations go to
brick house been calm and use promo code
Shapiro at checkout to get 15% off
discount easy to remember a brick house
bed because I am built like a brick
house guys brick house been calm use
promo code Shapiro a check out to get a
15% off discounts and if you're
listening to this podcast on your phone
you know the internet access right now
text Shapiro to four one four one one so
for one 411 for one four one one four a
text reminder for this promotion don't
forget to use promo code Shapiro at
checkout and get that 15% off try it I
promise you're gonna love it and they
kick lasts a lot longer than a cup of
coffee okay before I go further with
this just a couple empty nonsense and we
talked about the feminist movement and
how it's basically destroying I think
the future of sexual relations in the
it's relations between the sexes first
you're gonna have to pay us so go over
to daily wire calm right now
give us a $9.99 a month take out your
wallet take out that $10 bill send it to
us and when you do you'll get the rest
of this show live the rest of the under
Clavin show live the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live you get to be part
of our mailbag which we are doing
tomorrow have all of your questions
answered do it you'll love it also when
you get the annual subscription is
cheaper than the monthly go into that
same wallet if you have $100 bill send
it to us one time you don't have to
worry about it for the next 12 months
and you save yourselves 20 bucks and you
get this
the leftist here is hot real called
tumblr now let me explain this tumblr ok
this tumblr is just magnificent in every
possible way
you'll love every aspect of it and there
are people who say well Ben you talk
about civility and yet you you yourself
so and leftist here's how to recalled
tumblr right it doesn't say liberal
tears hot or cold because liberals are
people I can have a conversation with it
says leftist here's how I recall those
are the people who scream at the sky
after President Trump is elected and
then write op-eds for the New York Times
and their tears should be drunk okay
there it's it's not quite as healthy as
brick house energy but it's it's
relatively healthy not bad for you you
got a hydrate so go check it out right
now
replenish those electrolytes also go
subscribe over at YouTube or iTunes make
sure that you subscribe because we have
fantastic fantastic Sunday specials that
come out every single Sunday with great
guests we have this week micro who's
showing up and it'll be awesome
he's a hilarious dude and you'll really
enjoy this Sunday special it's a lot of
fun it was a lot of fun to do go check
that out
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so continuing on with our
good friend Jessica Pawlenty she says
whether it's misogynist terrorism the
rash of young men feeling sexually
entitled to women or the persistent
stereotype of real men as powerful and
violent it's never been clearer that
American boys are in desperate need of
intervention they are in desperate need
of intervention because you have robbed
them of purpose as I've said many times
when feminists say things like teach
boys not to rape you know I'm I think a
pretty good guy when I say a pretty good
guy I don't mean I'm nice to people
because come on I'm not nice to people
but I'm the the reality is that I was a
virgin until I was married I have very
high sexual standards for myself and I
did all the way up until the time that I
was married I am a I've been married for
10 years already I have two children
under the age of five I spend an awful
lot of time with them every single day I
take care of them I provide for them I
protect them I make sure I know how to
protect them right this is the stuff a
man should do when my father was
bringing me up my father never sat me
down and said Ben don't rape because no
one has ever said that in the history of
humanity it's like saying to someone son
don't murder no one says that what your
father teaches you what your parents
teach you is to be a good person and
what that means is taking responsibility
for others it's answering the question
that is asked by Cain in the book of
Genesis am I my brother's keeper and the
answer is you are your brother's keeper
and you are your sister's keeper and you
are you're taught that you are to
protect yourself and your family and
your civilization right these are the
things that make good men men who are
robbed of purpose become destructive
men who are robbed of purpose turn that
aggression outward men who are robbed of
purpose tend to hurt others in ways that
they are not even thinking about they
tend to treat other people as objects
now you want to know why men are
treating young women as objects because
they've not been taught that they are
supposed to have responsibility for
those women I don't mean there's no mum
I don't mean they're supposed to control
them I mean they're taught that they are
supposed to protect women if you're not
taught to protect women if you have a
bunch of young men who are never taught
their jobs to protect women and they're
taught that instead women are just these
things out there and you treat them as
you treat other things then you
shouldn't be surprised when men treat
women as objects which is a great great
evil hey but feminists get this all
wrong so Valenti says though feminists
have always recognized the anguish that
boys face in a patriarchal system
anguish we haven't built the same
structures of support for boys that we
for girls if we want to stop young men
from being taken in by sexism that has
to change well first you have to define
sexism but feminists left has an
unfortunate tendency to define sexism as
treating women nicely like opening a
door for a woman picking up the tab
saying that a woman looks pretty today
these are terrible terrible sins when
one of feminism's biggest successes
according to Valenti was creating an
alternative culture for girls and women
seeking respite from mainstream
constraints girls worried about
unrealistic beauty standards for example
can turn to the body positivity movement
those of us who find traditional media's
treatments of women unappealing can read
feminist blogs and magazines female
college students who have critical
questions about how gender shapes their
lives can take women's studies classes
all of these things make women less
happy I mean I'm just all of these
things you know although the idea that
women get happier by taking Women's
Studies classes I have never seen
unhappy or groups of people and women
who takes Women's Studies classes
seriously that is not a happy group of
people as a general rule just saying
okay also let's be clear about the
unrealistic body image standards you
know who buys women's magazines women
not men men are not making those
magazines men are not buying those
magazines you know who runs the the the
makeup industry billions and billions of
dollars and ain't then men don't care
ask your ask your boyfriend or your
husband ladies ask your boyfriend your
husband next time you spend a hundred
bucks on getting your nails done they
will not even notice men don't even care
men don't notice okay this is women
judging other women dirty little secret
women judge other women a lot more than
men judge women really okay from social
but Jessica Vaughn says all men from
social media campaigns to after school
equality clubs feminism has burned
dozens of online and real-life spaces
where girls can find alternatives to the
sexist status quo but boys and young men
who are struggling have no equivalent
culture as Sarah rich recently wrote in
the Atlantic while society is chipping
away at giving girls broader access to
life possibilities it isn't presenting
boys with a full continuum of how they
can be in the world this gap has made
boy susceptible to misogynist hucksters
peddling get manly quick platitudes and
dangerous online extremist communities
who does she uses her example
Jordan Peterson of course my friend
Jordan Peterson he's the example of
toxic masculinity
a guy who was married who has kids who
doesn't regularly get into fights or
rape people he is the great a guy whose
main takeaway his literal main
take away two boys's clean up your room
that's literally his take away he's
toxic masculinity why well because he
does not call students by their
preferred pronouns and he says that men
are in charge because they're better
suited for it okay his never said that
what he has said is that there are
hierarchies of competence in virtually
every area of life and that in a free
system those hierarchies are not going
to be evenly distributed in any area in
some areas women will do better in some
areas men will do better this is
absolutely true on every level it's
always been true in a free country
there will be hierarchies of competence
because there are in every area of life
there are hierarchies of competence in
basketball I fail at that hierarchy of
competence that is not because of racism
or sexism and some of mr. Peterson's
other claims the lens he says include
the idea that sexual harassment wouldn't
be such a problem if women didn't wear
makeup to work his never said that and
that enforced monogamy would stop young
men from committing mass murder he has
never said that either again we covered
this on the show a few weeks ago
absolutely I idiotic what he actually
said is that a system that encourages
monogamy is going to end up with an even
more evenly distributed sexual
distribution partners then a system
where a few men get a lot of women for
example but he doesn't say the
government should force women to get
married to a man and men should like he
doesn't say any of that stuff is just
made up online misogynist communities
offer similarly dangerous advice to
young men distressed over sexual
rejection instead of teaching them says
Jessica Valenti that their value has
nothing to do with their sexual
experience or that they are simply not
entitled to sexual attention no matter
how badly they want it in some forums
tell boys that the real problem is
women's freedom if women didn't have a
choice they say any man could have sex
with whomever he liked okay well I
myself have critiqued the insell
community exactly this way saying that
if you actually want to get a woman
perhaps you ought to act better perhaps
got to aim for marriage and commitment
and responsibility rather than just
aiming for random sex but the feminist
movement doesn't agree with that as they
think that marriage and responsibilities
are impediments to freedom I think that
they are the greatest indicator that you
have a societal basis for freedom and in
Jessica Valenti continue says feminism
feminist ideas can help men be it with
the rejection of expectations that men
be strong or stoic or ending the silence
around male victims of sexual violence
but boys also need the same kind of
culture we created for girls instead
what we need is is a new sort of system
a new support system this is white male
leaders and government corporations and
institutions vastly
women men have more cultural and
economic power than women but until we
grapple with how to stop misogynist
themselves starting with ensuring boys
don't grow up to be one women will never
be free and then she offers no actual
solutions except for we should have
Women's Studies classes to teach men not
to be men so solid solution there I
can't imagine why men are running
screaming away from away from the
feminist movement just I can't imagine
it now speaking of men running screaming
away from the feminist movement I got to
tell you about this insane paper it's
really funny this insane paper not from
an author and Helen Wilson is a
peer-reviewed journal okay it's a
peer-reviewed journal in in an actual
feminist academic journal and the
article is titled I kid you not human
reactions to rape culture and queer poor
my poor Matt performativity at urban dog
parks in Portland Oregon let me read
that again human reactions to rape
culture and queer performativity at hew
at urban dog parks in Portland Oregon I
can't even get it out it's so stupid and
it's based on approximately 1,000 hours
of observing dogs and their owners the
author Helen Wilson claims there was one
dog rape humping incident every 60
minutes so the dogs are sexist according
to Wilson this is not a joke the corn
Cassie Dylan over at Daily wire dog
parks are just the place to observe
toxic masculinity and heterosexuality
quote dog parks are microcosms or
hegemonic masculinity and queering
behavior and compulsory heterosexuality
can be observed in a cross-species
environment according to Wilson dog
parks are oppressive spaces that lock
both human and animals into hegemony
patterns of gender conformity adding a
pressure of patriarchal norms reached
Zenith reached their Zenith in dog parks
and then it gets even where nobody can
actually say whether this woman has a
PhD she says she has a PhD in feminist
studies and these the lead researcher
for the Portland on gender research
initiative so that the academic journal
is called the Journal of feminist
geography I can't believe this is real I
mean if this is real it's just it's just
unbelievable maybe one of the reasons
that heterosexuality is the norm in dog
parks is because dogs in order to
reproduce have to have sex with other
dogs of a different sex I'm not sure how
these dogs actually self-identify but I
don't think it matters at the dog park
because everything is terrible and we're
so just well done everyone why don't we
take women's studies more seriously
folks why don't we take feminism more
seriously nobody knows
speaking of idiotic ideas from from the
left Israel is under a lot of flak
lately the State of Israel is under a
lot of flack because they pushed through
a new law calling Israel the
nation-state of the Jewish people now I
was unaware that Israel is not the
nation-state of the Jewish people the
Declaration of Independence of the State
of Israel it says it's the nation-state
for the Jewish people it is called the
Jewish state there's a reason that it
was called that the reason that the
Parliament actually passed this law is
because the courts in Israel are even
more leftist than they are in the United
States and there are a bunch of attempts
by the Supreme Court of the State of
Israel to essentially rewrite all of the
basic laws in Israel to not make Israel
a Jewish state now then a lot of people
say Israel is ethnocentric of Jewish
state Israel is not ethnocentrism less
you consider Latvia ethnocentrism less
you consider France ethnocentric okay
there are lots of countries that are
made for the people who are in them
America is a land for Americans now it's
great about America is you can become an
American what's great about Israel is
that you can become a citizen and become
a Jew right Judaism is not something
that you are only born with you can
actually convert into becoming a Jew I
also notice that all the people who are
very upset with the idea of a Jewish
state have no problem whatsoever with a
Palestinian state that will be run under
Islamic law and will have zero Jews
living in it whereas 20% of all people
living in the State of Israel are
actually Arab a 20% of people living in
Israel are Arab and most the vast
majority of those people are Muslim when
in fact when asked Israeli Arabs do not
want to leave Israel and move into the
non-existent State of Palestine they
don't want to leave and move into a
Muslim country because they have it
better in Israel but an article in The
New York Times says Israel is terrible
because democracy and Judaism cannot
coexist weird how you're allowed to say
that in the pages of the New York Times
but you can't say that Islam and
democracy can't coexist so just to get
this straight according to the left
Christianity and democracy can't coexist
even though they have coexisted and
democracy was basically born inside
Christian countries Judaism and
democracy can't coexist even though
Israel is in fact a Jewish and
democratic state but Islam and democracy
can coexist even though they're
precisely zero actual major Islamic
democracies like serious Islamic
democracy is the closest thing that you
might have is something like Indonesia
even though there are significant
restrictions on democracy okay but
according to the New York Times it's
very very
that Israel says that it is now a
nation-state of the Jewish people Israel
also made Hebrew its official language
which originally it was I guess Hebrew
and Arabic and English but that was a
holdover from British Palestine mandate
so they have said that Hebrews the
official language but these other two
languages are given quasi official
status so now Israel is apparently evil
evil evil evil it's really amazing the
the this editorial in the New York Times
suggests that the nation state law is
terrible they say that that Judaism
cannot coexist because the minute the
Judaism and democracy are attempting to
coexist then you are writing non-jews
out of the of the Declaration of
Israel's independence and the State of
Israel that is simply not true Arab
parties sit in Israelis Parliament the
only thing that this really does in
reality is prevent the Supreme Court of
the State of Israel from cramming down a
bunch of leftism though to undermine the
identity of the State of Israel in order
to promote a leftist view of what the
State of Israel ought to be okay so
we're gonna have to now some things I
like and then we'll do some things I
hate and then we'll get out of here so
things I like when doing jazz all week
one of the great jazz pianists of all
time is a guy named Erol Garner you
probably don't know Erroll Garner stuff
because much older pianist but terrific
terrific jazz pianist this is from a cut
they can't take that away from me and it
really is fantastic the album is concert
by the sea and Erroll Garner is the
pianist
[Music]
it really swings he was also famous for
the fact that um he was very short
instead she's 5 foot 2 he's to perform
sitting on multiple telephone
directories I have sympathy
um so Erroll Garner go listen to that
albums great concert by the CL Gardner
it really is terrific okay other things
that I like you know good news never
gets enough attention and this I thought
was a great story so a police officer
was was confronted with a homeless man
who was wanted to go in for a job
interview the man was named Phil he
reportedly went to McDonald's in
Tallahassee to apply for a job but he
was told he couldn't be hired unless he
shaved his beard Phil started shaving
his thick beard in a gas station parking
lot without a mirror and then officer
Tony Carlson came up he saw the man
struggling so he came by he tightened
the screw on Phil's razor and then
proceeded to shave Phil's face for him
and somebody captured this video and
went viral here's what it looked like
yeah you can't really hear it but what
you can see is this police officer who's
actually shaving this homeless man so he
can go in and apply for a job and the
officer said if he's wanting to help
himself I need to be more careful more
than careful and tried to help him out
the best that I can just a great story
of human beings helping other human
beings for all the stories about we only
see the stories about the police when
the police are shooting somebody you
never see the stories about how often
the police actually help people and a
lot of great police officers out there
doing a lot of wonderful things okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so
representative Joe Crowley not long for
Congress because he was defeated in a
primary by everybody's favorite
socialist Alexandria Ocasio Cortes I am
getting better at saying her name Joe
Crowley came out yesterday
and he said that he has an idea you know
what where Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
merely says that I should be abolished
Joe Crowley says we should pay the
families of illegal immigrants yes
really this is a thing that happened in
real life I suggest they need to be
compensated for what this administration
I did you know the first formal
compensation needs to be the full Rena
from unification obvious Emily's okay so
reunify the families fine but then we
should pay them they cross the border
illegally and then cost us a lot
of money how what why where when how who
me none of this makes any sense but it
is it is obvious right now that members
of both parties but particularly
Democrats are really catering to a
hardcore radical base in the more
radical you are the more popular you are
which is why I'm Maxine Waters who is a
full-fledged nutjob is now aunty Maxine
inside the Democratic Party this is why
you know when I said earlier on the show
that I think President Obama President
Trump rather needs to do better with the
rhetoric because Democrats cannot be
allowed to win Congress if Democrats win
Congress if they win the Senate there
won't be any judges there won't be
anything that that gets done it'll be a
bunch of radical proposals and
investigations for the next two years
and if Trump loses reelection on the
back of that and you have a Democratic
president with Democrats in the House
and Senate look for things to get wild
and terrible as fast as humanly possible
the pendulum swings in this country and
it swung to the right for a bit and we
got to be very careful it doesn't swing
back to the left because when it does
it's gonna swing back to people like Joe
Crowley and Alexandra Ocasio Cortes and
her democratic socialism so we got to be
very very careful here okay we'll be
back here tomorrow with all the latest
news updates i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
Ford publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018